las noticias también son económicas con
danielle hablando en francés 24 daniela
buenas noches para ustedes hola buenas
noches angela vamos a comenzar haciendo
el repaso de una noticia que se anunció
en los últimos días y es la decisiones
de los países de la unión europea de
eeuu y de otros socios de excluir bancos
rusos del sistema swift quiero empezar
preguntándole qué es este sistema que se
ha club excluido
del que han sido excluidos la mayoría de
instituciones financieras rusas pues de
angela siguiendo los pasos de eeuu
también de canadá y de otros países una
de las más recientes sanciones de la
unión europea contra rusia por su
invasión a ucrania tiene que ver
justamente con la exclusión de siete
bancos rusos del sistema swift con las
opciones de doses bomba y gazprombank
porque son los que tramitan digamos las
exportaciones petroleras y gasíferas
esta es una cooperativa de sociedades
financieras creadas en bruselas en 1973
que permite el envío y la recepción de
dinero entre bancos de todo el mundo y
le voy a dar un ejemplo cuando un
cliente realiza una transferencia
internacional a favor de otro co genera
un mensaje cifrado que indica todos los
detalles de cómo se va a recibir ese
dinero de esta manera se proporciona
seguridad y es tan importante que a
veces inclusive se le llama el sistema
nervioso central de la banca mundial
pues desde que se anexó crimea en 2014
rusia ha venido desarrollando su propio
sistema homólogo llamado sp fs y china
también tiene el suyo bueno y entonces
cuál es la diferencia pues la diferencia
es que el swift es utilizado hoy por
11.000 instituciones financieras en 200
países o territorios mientras que en el
homólogo ruso apenas participan 399
instituciones en 10 territorios el de
china que es un poco más desarrollado y
que se llama ips tiene
1280 usuarios en 103 países o
territorios y fue creado para
internacionalizar el uso del yuan
también lo venden como un sistema ideal
para quienes quieren evitar el riesgo de
exponer sus transacciones a eeuu rusia
hasta entonces invitando a sus
instituciones a que se unan a su
proyecto para reducir el impacto de la
desconexión de su banca del sistema
y mire los precios de los commodities
están imparables por cuenta de la guerra
cuáles son sus efectos sobre la economía
están disparados angela no solamente el
precio del petróleo del que vamos a
hablar que inició la semana en poco más
de 90 dólares y apenas dos días después
o tres días después ya pasa los 110
dólares en sus dos referencias el frente
de entrega en europa y el w y en el
golfo de mexico esta es una situación
que también se notan los metales como el
cobre y el níquel o el aluminio que
están subiendo a precios no vistos hace
años el efecto se mide según el
beneficiario colombia o méxico por
ejemplo son exportadores de petróleo y
chile es el mayor productor mundial de
cobre por lo que la crisis les genera
más ingresos pero también habrá efectos
negativos como nos lo explica desde
chile el analista ricardo nadie
lo que significa también que se va a
endurecer el precio de todo lo que es la
línea de producción la cadena de
producción y que sirve con el petróleo
nato que me refiero a los transportes
las comunicaciones la conexión actual
con petróleo y también el tema de la
alimentación el transporte de pasajeros
todo va a subir desgraciadamente en
consideración lo que está pasando en tu
cráneo y rusia- y también a entender
todo lo que significa la exportación por
ejemplo del eléctrico que también hay un
tema que se está todavía discutiendo la
exportación de trigo es un tema
importante entendiendo que tanto rusia
como ucrania solo principal exportador
ya está a nivel europeo también que a
nivel oriental del trigo entonces
claramente se aumenta el precio del
trigo también nombre te lesionas que las
cosas que funcionan contigo en este caso
la harina el pan que supuestamente las
bases de lo que significa el trigo el
momento del trigo va a aumentar todo es
pérez nos vemos como nos va a afectar a
todos y en lo más preocupante es que el
precio del petróleo puede seguir
subiendo porque la opep más en la que
está rusia decidió subir muy poco su
oferta de crudo arroz ya también le
conviene que los precios del crudo estén
altos
daniela y la unión europea pondrá sobre
la lupa el uso de cristo de divisas en
rusia porque mire porque rusia y ucrania
fueron los primeros en adoptar la
tecnología block change que es la que
respalda las cripto monedas y ahora con
un conflicto en pleno apogeo este
mercado se está disparando el gobierno
de ucrania ha recibido alrededor de 35
millones de dólares en donaciones con
cripto activos y la otra cara de la
moneda tiene que ver con que como extras
esas transacciones no son vigiladas por
las autoridades se teme que en rusia las
utilicen para evadir las sanciones que
le ha impuesto occidente escuchamos y
hemos sido informados de que hay un
aumento del volumen de transacciones con
cripto monedas y cripto activos lo que
podría indicar intentos de evadir las
sanciones a través de ese sistema son
sandwiches así que es algo que vamos a
evaluar y si es necesario proponer
medidas contra ello
hemos decidido trabajar en medidas
suplementarias para aún más la eficacia
de las sanciones y evitar toda ilusión
disensión visite y parís france titán y
pareciera daniele le quiero pedir su
ronda con los indicadores de la jornada
bueno comencemos con moscú que por
tercer día consecutivo permaneció
cerrada esta bolsa y los mercados en
general rebotaron después de varias
jornadas en rojo en wall street end se
concentraron más en las declaraciones
del presidente de la reserva federal
quien dijo que la subida de tasas de
interés en marzo podría ser menor a la
que temen algunos inversionistas y
también lo hicieron las bolsas europeas
cerraron en positivo más por el hecho de
que el aumento en los precios de los
commodities hizo que subieran las
acciones de algunas mineras en el a
gracias a ustedes ya nuestros
televidentes que continúen en france24
ya volvemos
[Música]